was müssen wir tun um den klimawandel
noch in den griff zu kriegen
das ist eine frage die hätten wir schon
so vor 20 jahren uns stellen können aber
es dauert ja manchmal bis solche
erkenntnisse auch beim letzten
angekommen sind und es gibt ja noch
immer leute die das nicht so richtig
wahrhaben wollen die groko gehört so ja
mal halb dazu nabucco 1 und kroko zwei
die haben immer vor allem warme worte
gemacht zur erderwärmung richtig
passiert ist da nichts kroko drei will
es jetzt richten sie haben sich
zusammengesetzt es gibt ein klima
kabinett dass einige monate lang getagt
hat und heute sitzen sie zusammen um das
klimaschutz 2030 zu beschließen wird zur
stunde noch diskutiert ob das ausreicht
und was man vielleicht noch tun müsste
oder tun sollte das werden wir heute
besprechen mit dem mann der im zdf die
wissenschaft am besten erklären kann
nämlich mit dem astrophysiker und tara
ex moderator harald lesch der steht
heute in jena vor dem klima pavillon hat
einen vortrag gehalten
sie haben als physiker kenne sie und sie
habe als physiker jetzt gerade eine
klima doku im zdf gemacht gibt es auch
übrigens in der mediathek gucken dass
man ein bisschen was man an
wie kamen sie denn dazu klimawandel ist
doch jetzt eigentlich nichts ihr
hausgemachtes wissenschafts milieu oder
also ich bin theoretischer physiker und
klimawandel ist physik vor allen dingen
und an allererster stelle eben physik
wie reagierten system darauf dass die
anzahl von bestimmten molekülen sich
erhöht das ist im grunde genommen das
physikalische grundproblem
und wie reagiert ein komplexes system
dann darauf auf komplexe art und weise
die ganzen rückkopplungen also das
gehört nicht direkt zu meinem geschäft
als astrophysiker aber zu meinem
geschäft theoretischer physiker gehört
das dazu
und das muss man immer wieder sagen
klimawandel ist keine erfindung von von
irgendjemand sondern klimawandel ist
physik es ist genau die gleiche physik
die dafür sorgt dass wir beide uns jetzt
überhaupt unterhalten können dass sich
aufgenommen werden kann
das ist nämlich die gleiche musik die
dafür sorgt dass wir verstanden haben
wie materie mit elektromagnetischer
strahlung wechseln werden die doku haben
wir gerade schon gesagt die lief schon
im fernsehen vor zwei tagen gibt's
natürlich weiter in der zdf mediathek
noch ein ganzes jahr das sind schon
ziemlich krasse bilder
wir haben die mal ein bisschen für euch
zusammengerafft das hat mein kollege
thomas garcia für uns gemacht
70 prozent des deutschen waldbestandes
werden mittlerweile als geschädigt
eingestuft und das ist nur ein winziger
ausschnitt des weltweit dramatischen
geschehens
die erwärmung lässt sich nicht durch
natürliche faktoren erklären
sie ist menschen insbesondere durch die
nutzung fossiler brennstoffe
[Musik]
wenn wir nicht in den nächsten jahren
und jahrzehnten dramatisch umsteuern
riskieren wir den kollaps des klimas und
das ende unserer gesellschaft noch ist
es nicht soweit aber es ist unsere
letzte chance
tja eine klare ansage unter anderem von
professor harald lesch und sonst eher
wissenschaftsexperte klimawandel die
fakten mit harald lesch so heißt die
doku gibt es eben noch habe ich gerade
gesagt in der zdf mediathek zu sehen es
lohnt sich
und wir reden heute mit ihnen über die
frage was müssen wir jetzt tun
herrlich ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe
mich schon vor über 20 jahren gegen zu
viel autoverkehr zum beispiel auf die
straße gestellt
das thema waren hier durchaus bewusst
ich habe mir ihre doku angeguckt und hab
gedacht verdammt ich habe drei töchter
in die welt gesetzt das war glaube ich
bekloppt die idee war es dass das ist
glaube ich nicht denke wenn wir es
wirklich schaffen können wenn die
politik ist wirklich hinbekommt so
schnell wie möglich richtig viel
erneuerbare energien auszubauen
raus aus den fossilien zu kommen
wirklich mit voller wucht und ohne und
ohne diese ständigen rückzugsgefechte
wir müssten wir könnten uns wenn wir es
wirklich tun dann ist das noch zu
handeln wenn wir es allerdings für
vermasseln dann müssen ihre drei töchter
eben auch damit irgendwie klarkommen
das ist dann schon eine ziemliche
herausforderung aber sie sprechen in der
doku ich habe auf die worte geachtet von
klimawandel eindämmen
sie sprechen nicht davon aufhalten die
das vor zehn zwanzig jahren noch der
fall war ist es also zu spät tatsächlich
das rad zurückzudrehen und zu sagen das
wird sie nicht mehr ändern
das lässt sich auf jeden fall innerhalb
von ein zwei menschenleben nicht mehr so
ohne weiteres verändern wir werden uns
anpassen müssen wir müssen aber vor
allem dafür sorgen dass eben diese
ganzen kennzahlen der konzentration von
treibhausgasen endlich mal aufhören zu
steigen also das wäre ja schon fast eine
gelegenheit mal zu feiern denn wenn der
co2 aus anstieg aufhören würde in der
tat ist es so dass wir auf dem tanker
sinn wo wir nicht so ohne weiteres das
steuer herumreißen können und dann
bewegt der tank dass ich direkt in die
richtung über das gerne hätten sondern
es wird sehr lange dauern
wir können eigentlich jetzt erst
anfangen das ist ein bisschen wie der
kathedralen bau mittelalter
da wussten diejenigen die den grundstein
legen auch dass sie denen das ende das
ganz
nicht mehr erleben werden wir müssen
hier tatsächlich über generationen
müssen wir diese energiewende vollziehen
das wird vor allen dingen jetzt am
anfang ganz ganz ganz wichtig seien sehr
schnell einzusteigen die erneuerbaren
mit voller wucht mit allem was geht mit
speicher mit netzwerken und so weiter
auch zum beispiel gestatten dass
hochspannungs gleichstrom
gleichstromkabel angedockt werden sie
dass wir möglichkeiten haben in norwegen
überschüssige wind power zb zu speichern
das muss alles gemacht werden und zwar
schnell und ohne wenn und aber ansonsten
wird es wirklich katastrophal ich kann
die die bilder die wir da zeigen sind
dramatisch und es sind noch nicht die
schlimmsten man könnte es man hätte es
noch viel schlimmer machen können das
wollte ich gerade fragen also ich man
kriegt bei der doku schon so ein
bisschen schlechte laune und das ist das
gefühl das ist alles sehr
weltuntergangsszenario woran sehen sie
doch woran haben sie in der recherche
den ganz konkret gesehen dass das was
wir früher als zukunfts szenario
entworfen haben mittlerweile schon
realität ist
wer sind die beschleunigten vorgänger
überall ob es die gletscherschmelze ist
in grönland die gletscherschmelze in der
also die die verschwinden des arktischen
meereises ist das verschwinden des
antarktischen eises die art und weise
wie die vegetationsperiode sich
verändern wie die vegetationszonen sich
verändern wie stark die extrem wird der
ereignisse zugenommen haben und zwar
wirklich die ausschläge auch zugenommen
haben und wie inzwischen deutlich wird
dass die wahrscheinlichkeit für solche
richtig massiven also sozusagen extreme
extremwerte ereignisse zu nehmen dass
das immer mehr und mehr zunimmt die
wärme die erde wird und das bei einer
bei den globalen temperaturanstieg von
einem grad wenn das noch mehr wird dann
wird es neben noch stärker und momentan
ist es so dass selbst die
pessimistischsten szenarien immer noch
viel zu optimistisch waren
und das ist eben der punkt wir können
das vergleichen mit den szenarien aus
den 90ern aus den nullerjahren und
stellen dann fest werde noch viel zu
optimistisch selbst dann wenn sie schon
ziemlich pessimistisch waren es ist
alles noch viel schlimmer geworden
die treibhausgase wirkung seit 1990 hat
sich verdoppelt und momentan ist kein
ende in sicht aber wenn ich mir das
jetzt mal anguckt auch hier was in den
kommentaren steht gibt es wieder einen
ich zum sieg gibt uns effekt um
signifikanten anteil so als würde ich
ein kluges worten nutzen abgleichs
versagt also es gibt einen bedeutenden
anteil von leuten die wieder sagen dass
es
klima hysterie das stimmt alles nicht
das ist völlig übertrieben das ist
panikmache
was sagen sie diesen menschen die das
nicht wahrhaben wollen was sie und
andere wissenschaftliche stelle haben
gehen sie zum förster gehen sie zu im
land gehen sie zu den landwirten gehen
sie zu den winzern gehen sie zu den
menschen die davon leben was aus dem
boden kommt reden sie mit dem wasser mit
den leuten die für die wasserversorgung
zuständig sind
reden sie einfach mit all denjenigen die
tag für tag jetzt bereits mit dem
klimawandel zu tun haben wenn sie uns
wissenschaftler nicht glauben dann reden
sie mit der münchener rückversicherung
das ist ja eine
versicherungsgesellschaft die
versicherung versichert und da geht es
zum beispiel um geld die haben seit 50
jahren eine geo risiko abteilung mit den
besten datensatz über
extremwetterereignisse auf der ganzen
welt reden sie mit den leuten und
ansonsten kann ich allen nur sagen ihr
die ihr tatsächlich klima skeptisch seid
ihr benutzt die technologien die aus der
physik herauskommen die eben auch
herausgefunden hat wie der klimawandel
funktioniert also das ist eine solche
unglaubwürdige doppel zügigkeit auf der
einen seite die physik gerne zu begrüßen
wenn sie einen technologien gibt mit
denen man tag für tag irgendwie ein ganz
gutes leben führen kann
aber wenn dann schlechte nachrichten von
dieser physik kommen dann heißt es nun
ohne not das ist dann alles hysterie
da kann ich eigentlich gar nur noch
schmunzeln darüber ich habe ja schon so
ein paar kommentare zusammen aus unserer
zuschauerschaft manchmal sagt annalena
auf facebook ganz klar klare kante
zeigen wir müssen alle endlich raus aus
der komfortzone kai uwe schmidt sagt
sehr drastisch auch auf facebook aber
was nützt denn unsere klima wände sind
rund um deutschland alle anderen drauf
scheißen zitat ist nicht mein also hat
er damit nicht noch ein bunter na ja es
ist so deutschland ist die stärkste
industrie nation der welt wir verbreiten
ja genau die mittel mit denen der
gesamte globus ganz massiv verändert
wird wir sind ja ganz stark an dem
wirtschaftswachstum in allen möglichen
ländern beteiligt und hier die richtigen
produkte anzubieten und sie dann auch
möglicherweise zu verschenken
das wird die aufgabe sein wir sind so
reich wir zu den reichsten ländern der
welt wie diese aufgabe
wir sind ganz erheblich an dem ausstoß
von co2 in den letzten jahrzehnten und
jahrhunderten gewesen
das heißt es ist unsere aufgabe das
jetzt zu machen
und man nur nichts hat mehr sex als
erfolg und wenn das erfolgreich ist dann
machen die anderen ländern auch mit und
nicht anzufangen wäre eine viel zu große
sünde so jetzt gerade bis sind die
physik tatsächlich verlassen sie waren
ganz kurz weg ich hoffe das bleibt nicht
so nein ich bin hier immer noch da so
seine meinung vertreten und die
vermietungsphase funktioniere ja ja ja
jetzt haben wir gerade schon
angesprochen wir machen was wir müssen
was machen es passiert aber gerade ganz
viel auf der welt in sachen klima einmal
geht es morgen weltweit die erste größte
weltweite freddys for future demo und
die streiken erste woche ist der
un-klimagipfel in new york heute nacht
haben wir da schon gesagt berät die
bundesregierung über ihr klima paket die
wissen aber immer noch nicht so richtig
was da jetzt drin stehen wird und unsere
hauptstadt korrespondent in chuck und
hat ab energy ist vor ort guckt sich das
an
hört sich das an und hat uns das hier
geschickt was gerade der stand ist und
einige dieser fragen sind wohl immer
noch offen das haben wir heute in einem
entwurf gesehen eines
klimaschutzprogramms 20.30 das ist heute
bekannt gewordenen entwurf von montag
montagabend und da gibt es eben noch
einige offene stellen zum beispiel bei
der co2 einsparung bringen die
vorschläge der bundesregierung weniger
als die hälfte dessen was man sich für
zwanzig dreißig vorgenommen hat den rest
will man erreichen durch die verteuerung
von co2 aber da ist eben noch offen wie
macht man das mit einem emissionshandel
oder mit einer co2 steuer da sind sich
die partner noch nicht einig offen ist
auch noch die frage wie viel kostet der
klimaschutz vor allem bei den
investitionen die man in
klimafreundliche technologien noch
stecken möchte von einem dreistelligen
milliardenbetrag ist in dem entwurf den
wir heute gesehen haben die rede
mal gucken ob er heute abend noch mehr
dazu kommt wenn sich die beiden parteien
hier miteinander zusammen setzen und man
könnte sagen die koalition nimmt sich
hier so etwas vor wie die quadratur des
kreises sie möchte nämlich klimaschutz
mit wirtschaftswachstum und
sozialverträglichkeit versöhnen
ob das alles gelingen kann das ist die
große große frage alle beteiligten sagen
auf jeden fall sie werden mal mindestens
die nacht über brauchen und bis morgen
mittag soll der vorschlag dann stehen
soweit also energy unserer hauptstadt
korrespondentin mit dem aktuellen stand
zu den verhandlungen
in berlin ich guck mal gerne in die
kommentare hier zum beispiel war das hat
unmittelbar damit zu tun thomas wüst
schreibt auf periskop ich habe mich
heute nach einer elektrotankstelle für
meinen außenstelle platz erkundigt
privat 0 förderung kosten für die
elektrifizierung eines außen
stellplatzes ca 8000 euro also er fühlt
sich damit alleine gelassen
jetzt meine frage an sie herr lesch wäre
wenn sie jetzt hören das bedürfnis aber
es wird nicht richtig gefördert die
regierung kann sich immer noch nicht
einigen was sie eigentlich möchte was
denken sie da das möchte ich lieber
nicht sagen
ich finde es ich finde es ehrlich gesagt
erbärmlich ich meine das ist ja nicht
das erste große klimapaket die anderen
die klangen ja auch schon ganz großartig
dass wir die klimaziele 2020 nicht
erreicht haben ist erbärmlich dass wir
20 30 nicht erreichen ist noch
erbärmlicher gut aber da man sich ganz
allgemein aber auch gleich informiert
bin aber war das ja selbst hoch so hoch
gesteckt
also das war ja eigentlich schon mehr
machen müssen
ja aber dann wäre hätte man wenigstens
mal versuchen sollen dann richtig dran
zu gehen stattdessen haben wir zum also
ich denke es ist eine erbärmliche
situation wenn tatsächlich solche
entscheidungen wo es um ganz große dinge
geht in einer nachtsitzung entschieden
werden müssen
das kann doch nicht wahr sein ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht aber ich habe in
nachtsitzungen noch nie richtig was auf
die beine gestellt was dann wirklich
auch funktioniert hat das klingt ja erst
so nach einer nach der sitzung von
arbeitnehmern und arbeitgebern
gewerkschaften und und und arbeit
arbeitgeber die sich dann auf
irgendwelche zahlen einigen hier geht es
um eine um eine ganz große und wichtige
angelegenheit die kann man doch nicht in
der nachtsitzung besprechen die muss man
doch tagsüber mit klarem kopf bei hellem
bei hellem tageslicht besprechen und
nicht in der nacht du musst dann darum
geht wer gewinnt den gesäß oder gehirn
wissen sie das ist doch das doch
aberwitzig eine solche komplexe und
komplizierte angelegenheit in der
nachtsitzung zu besprechen
also es ist doch völlig eindeutig wenn
nicht das klima kabinette schafft dass
der ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
schneller wird einfacher wird die
genehmigungsverfahren schneller werden
wenn es uns nicht gelingt die netze
auszubauen die speichertechnologie
hinzusetzen dann brauchen wir über alle
anderen geschichten nicht zu sprechen
wenn wir wenn es uns nicht gelingt
endlich das ordnungsrechtlich durch
zugreifen ich höre ja immer wieder dass
gerne davon gesprochen wir wollen keine
verbote alles freiwillig ich kann mich
nicht erinnern dass ist das in
deutschland zb bei der einführung der
grenz geschwindigkeiten für geschlossene
ortschaften oder für landstraßen dass
man da groß drauf gesetzt hat dass der
deutsche autofahrer die deutsche
autofahrerin das freiwillig tun wird
nein da mal ganz klare grenzen gesetzt
und jetzt hier tun wir so als dürften
wir den leuten aufgrund ich weiß nicht
warum einfach nichts mehr verbieten ist
doch idiotisch mit der natur kann ich
nur immer wieder sagen lässt sich nicht
verhandeln
wenn das so weiter geht dann muss ich
befürchten dass es in deutschland
tatsächlich einer naturkatastrophe
braucht das politik reagiert praktisch
so eine art von sturmflut oder so was
das dann endlich mal tatsächlich
entscheidungen getroffen werden die dann
wahrscheinlich von allen akzeptiert
werden weil damals noch einmal alle
merken verdammt noch mal das hätten wir
schon längst klären müssen also ich bin
enttäuscht darüber dass die regierung
sich jetzt tatsächlich das kabinett sich
jetzt tatsächlich hinsetzt und in einer
nachtsitzung ein solches programm
verabschieden will
das ist schlimm und ich kann nur sagen
freitags for future das ist die einzige
bewegung offenbar die immer wieder
darauf hinweist wir müssen die
wissenschaftler ernst nehmen alle
anderen haben offenbar noch ganz andere
interessen im spiel und deswegen kommen
wir da eben nicht zu einer vernünftigen
entscheidung wie sie eigentlich schon
längst auf dem tisch nicht alle wissen
was getan werden muss und ich kann nur
sagen also los jetzt macht das ähnlich
und hört auf euch darum herum zu drücken
da geht es nicht um irgendwelche wahl
perspektiven für die eine oder andere
partei
da geht es um was ganz ganz ganz anderes
so soweit harald lesch ich glaube im
netz nennt das einen raid teams den sich
hier gerade abgeliefert haben ich kann
aber als auch so weiß ich nicht aber das
war mir ist mir immer wichtig gewesen ja
dass das arme gemerkt und ist auch
völlig legitim
als auto als moderator einer nacht
nachrichten sind und kann ich auch
bestätigen
je später der abend desto schwieriger
die konzentration also von daher haben
sie dort gemacht hat wir haben hier
viele verschiedene fragen ich versuche
mal ein bisschen zu sammeln also floh
wollte wissen sollte es eine
internationale klima vereinigung geben
die ähnlich aufgebaut wird wie die un
international dauert immer sehr lange
wir sollten uns immer darauf erst mal
zurückziehen was können wir national
machen um dann mit anderen zusammen was
zu machen
diese in der diskussion darauf
hinzuweisen
national kann man das ja gar nicht
national können wir ja gar nicht klären
wir müssen das international machen ist
immer ein verschiebebahnhof in das
nächste jahrzehnt oder das übernächste
jahrzehnten nichts da wir machen jetzt
hier unser ding wir machen es richtig
wir machen uns stark machen es
erfolgreich und dann ziehen die anderen
auch schon mit was ich vorhin schon
gesagt hat nichts hat mir 6 1 erfolg ich
kann ihnen gerade schon mal rückmelden
dass ihr ihre deutlichen worte seibert
angekommen sind hier plötzlich bedankt
bei psk tor auf periscope und auch jan
bruder schreibt auf youtube de regt sich
zu recht auf da haben sie also eine
breite unterstützung hier gab es noch
eine ganz interessante frage
ach so christian schreibt ihr auf
facebook klimaschutz ist auch ein
friedensprojekt so viele konflikte wegen
des erdöls geführt raus aus den fossilen
rein in die erneuerbaren ist es
tatsächlich so klimaschutzes auch
friedensprojekt friedens schutz ich
denke schon also nämlich für uns würde
das bedeuten dass zb unsere strategische
abhängigkeit bei der für die lieferung
von öl und gas die wäre nicht mehr so
groß damit werden natürlich automatisch
auch konfliktfelder entspannt keine
frage ja sicher ja so wir haben es
gerade schon gehört die groko verhandelt
gerade noch in berlin in einer
nachtsitzung ob die jetzt sinnvoll ist
oder nicht lasse ich mal dahingestellt
wo sie sich einig ist es zum ball
zumindest dass der co2 ausstoß
verringert werden soll in den bereichen
energiewirtschaft bauen verkehr
industrie und landwirtschaft und da soll
eine co2 bepreisung helfen aber es gibt
trotzdem immer noch eine reit punkt
nämlich steuer oder zertifikate handel
da kommen wir gleich zu hell es aber
erst mal erklärt uns die lia thomas was
da genau der unterschied ist
wer dem klima durch viel co2 schadet
muss dafür zahlen die idee es
naheliegend und nicht neu für
energieunternehmen energieintensive
industrie und für die luftfahrt gibt es
in europa schon länger den
emissionshandel unternehmen müssen
emissionszertifikate für von ihnen
produzierte treibhausgase erwerben
der ausstoß soll dadurch gedeckelt
werden
und weil die zertifikate reduziert und
verteuert werden müssen die unternehmen
klimafreundlicher werden das klingt gut
aber lange zeit war der preis so günstig
dass kaum in den klimaschutz investiert
wurde
trotzdem gibt es nun überlegungen zum
beispiel den verkehr in den europäischen
emissionshandel einzubeziehen
die andere idee eine co2 steuer auch
nicht neu schon vor 20 jahren versuchte
die politik durch steuern und
steuererhöhungen energiesparendes
verhalten in der gesellschaft zu fördern
der langfristige erfolg eher mäßig zum
beispiel ist der co2 ausstoß im verkehr
in den vergangenen jahren wieder
deutlich gestiegen
deshalb schlägt die
bundesumweltministerin vor eine co2
abgabe im rahmen der energie steuer
einzuführen betrifft also kraftstoffe
heizöl und gas zu beginn läge der preis
bei 35 euro pro tonne co2 und würde dann
jährlich um 14 euro 50 steigen
umgerechnet auf einen liter benzin würde
das zunächst eine preiserhöhung um rund
8 cent bedeuten
klar ist allerdings so eine abgabe
trifft menschen mit weniger geld und in
ländlichen gebieten härter und das so
sollte ausgeglichen werden zum beispiel
durch eine klima prämie die ausgezahlt
wird
die klimafreundlicher man sich verhält
desto mehr bleibt dann von der prämie
übrig und klar ist auch eine co2 abgabe
ist beim klimaschutz nur ein möglicher
baustein
denn sie bewirkt nicht automatisch dass
die klimaziele erreicht werden so über
die frage was können wir denn sonst noch
so tun sprechen wir heute mit unserem
zdf wissenschaftsexperte moderator
harald lesch der ein bisschen in china
gerade friert sie mussten schon ihren
tee zwischendurch nehmen es ist es ist
auch schon kalt draußen so ganz kurz was
ist denn ihr mittel der wahl steuer oder
zertifikate oder keins von beiden also
ich denke es muss beides zusammen kommen
wenn man wird die um die steuer am
anfang nicht herumkommen als eine
regelungs instrument aber unsere long
run also auch langfristig wird der
emissionshandel das tatsächlich machen
weil damit die menge die an kohlenstoff
kohlenstoff ausgestoßen werden kann
gedeckelt wird und mit hilfe der co2
steuer kann man aber eben tatsächlich
einen einfluss darauf nehmen wie viel
tatsächlich freigesetzt wird
ich denke mal wird beides tun müssen das
ist sozusagen die dritte variante die
aber offenbar von niemandem bis jetzt
politisch bedacht worden ist es geht
letztlich darum ob politik sich zutraut
ordnungsrechtlich so einzugreifen dass
das richtige passiert und nicht so tut
als könnte man hier sich baden ohne nass
zu werden klimaschutz kostet geld das
muss irgendwo herkommen und das sollten
wir uns auch gar keine illusion hingeben
ansonsten ich kann dann immer nur daran
erinnern das umweltbundesamt hat vor
einigen jahren eine broschüre
veröffentlicht da stehen
umweltschädliche subventionen drin in
deutschland werden zwischen 50 und 60
milliarden im jahr an umweltschädlichen
subventionen ausgegeben das heißt es ist
so dass wir noch nicht mal das richtige
tun sondern wir finanzieren auch noch
das falsche
also da könnte man glaube ich direkt
eingreifen und könnte dann vielleicht
auch dafür sorgen dass so ein
emissionshandel nach dem kohlendioxid
steuer sozial gut abgefedert
zu der zu ihrem kommentar gerade
klimaschutz kostet hat christian war auf
facebook geschrieben
was kostete klimaschutz ist die falsche
frage welche kosten verursachte
klimawandel für unsere nachfolgenden
generationen darum geht es doch dass das
so ist es lassen dass ich einmal sogar
stehen das ist die ganz große dimension
gibt es dennoch das wissen wir auch
schon den niklas stern report ich kann
sich jetzt ganz schwer verstehen da
gerade die bundesbahn hier vorbei fährt
wie diesen güterzug also ich möchte noch
mal daran erinnern wir hatten ja schon
von niklas stern vor über zehn jahren
schon ein bericht wie teuer der
klimawandel wird wenn wir nichts dagegen
tun ja ja da haben wir auch gerade noch
zahlen gelesen tatsächlich wird es mehr
kosten nichts zu tun als jetzt einfach
mal zu investieren wenn wir mal radikal
denken was würden sie am liebsten
eigentlich machen also es gibt ja doch
auch relativ wenig radikale lösungen dem
rettungs motoren verbieten
gibt es ja es gibt die möglichkeit co2
filter überall aufzustellen aufzustellen
es gibt ja die möglichkeit hier gab es
auch schon die frage kapitalismus
abschaffen
geht das überhaupt also das was ist so
ihre radikalste lösung vielmehr also
viele feiertage einführen und die leute
dazu verdonnern zu hause zu bleiben
das würde man tatsächlich deutlich
merken also nicht irgendwie übergang
also soll ich meinen flieger nach
mallorca
genau das sollte man an solchen tagen
wird die autobahn die wird autofrei sein
und die flughäfen werden flucht werden
nicht abheben so was stelle ich mir
vorstelle mir vor ein land das deutlich
ruhiger und langsamer ist aber vor allen
dingen würde ich dafür sorgen wenn ich
also richtig radikal halte ich an den
ausbau der erneuerbaren und zwar so
schnell und intensiv wie es nur geht die
leitungen müssen gebaut werden die netze
müssen her die speicher müssen her
es muss alles was an elektrischer
energie zur verfügung steht eben
verwandelt werden also power to freezing
ob das power to gas oder was auch immer
und das wirklich mit mit voller wucht
eingestiegen wird und dass es nicht sich
mit irgendwelchen kleinen netten
petitessen es sich da abgegeben wird und
das ganze wird dann zusammen
klimaschutzpaket dann verkauft sondern
dann sollte man lieber die finger davon
lassen sollte man den leuten reinen wein
einschenken wir können es nicht und wir
müssen damit leben dass die natur sich
eben dann in ab
die baarer zeit noch extremer uns
zuwendeten wir noch größere probleme
haben in unseren wäldern mit dem wasser
mit der luft aber nicht so tun als wenn
hier jetzt großartig irgendwas getan
wird was dann letzten endes wieder genau
so elend und erbärmlich endet wie das
was bis jetzt gemacht worden hier habe
ich entweder den rechtsstreit endlich
aufhören die finde ich ganz interessant
weil windräder wäre ja eine möglichkeit
nah und leider schreibt auf youtube
vielleicht kann man mal kurz rein gehen
windräder werden in deutschland
blockiert wegen klagen der anwohner oder
auch weil hunderttausende vögel an ihnen
verändern wie würden sie dieses problem
angehen
also erstmal ordnungsrechtliche ist es
klar dass natürlich diese ganze klage
sei das kann nicht das also man muss
einfach sehen wenn der globale
klimawandel kommt oder noch stärker wird
dann werden die haben die vögel keine
chance egal ob die windräder sich drin
oder nicht dann wird es so heiß werden
wie wir das ja auch in dem film gezeigt
haben in australien und die winterstürme
gefallen
genau da war es so heiß genau dass die
fledermäuse vom himmel gefallen sind von
den bäumen runter gefallen sind aber die
zahlen die da immer kolportiert werden
über die zerstörung von von
vogelpopulationen durch windräder die
sind angesichts also die sind glaube ich
dort deutlich übertrieben ich kann daher
ich habe dir jetzt die ich habe meine
unterlagen jetzt nicht hier dabei aber
man muss sich darüber im klaren sein
dass die ganze art und weise wie wir in
europa leben
die art und weise wie wir mobil sind und
so weiter dass das jeden tag tausende
von vögeln das leben kostet und davon
spricht keiner weder der auto fährt noch
sonst irgendwie mit zügen unterwegs ist
und so weiter also die windräder haben
einen einfluss es keine frage aber
entweder wir entscheiden uns für die
erneuerbaren energien
dann müssen wir damit leben dass wir
schäden anrichten oder wir tun es nicht
im übrigen kann ich nur sagen die größte
gefahr für die vogelpopulation in
deutschland ist der insekten verlust und
nicht die windräder
viele versuchen sich ja trotzdem jetzt
schon einzuschränken und irgendwie was
zu tun also weniger fleisch essen oder
gar nicht fleisch essen nicht mehr
fliegen weniger autofahren müll
vermeiden da gibt es ja viele strategien
bringt das denn überhaupt sei es ist das
ist das nicht ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein
das ist ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
aber es bringt trotzdem was ist nämlich
für einen selber ganz wichtig dass mich
das gefühl hat total hilflos daher zu
stehen und zum anderen kann eben dadurch
dass man das dass es mit vielen anderen
zusammen gemacht
wird und man sich dann auch ein bisschen
solidarisiert ist das eine ganz wichtige
grundlage sozusagen umwelt psychologisch
wie können wir versuchen
himalaya-gebirge bestehen nichts desto
weniger brauchen wir die ganz großen
aktion nämlich den ausbau der
erneuerbaren
es nutzt ja nichts sich irgendwelche
elektro geräte anzuschaffen auch
elektroautomobile wenn dann der größte
teil des stromes wenig verbraucher immer
noch nicht erneuerbar hergestellt wird
für die natur selber ist der einzige
entscheidende effekt dass wir es
schaffen weniger kohlenstoff moleküle in
die atmosphäre zu bringen dass das abend
das alles andere ist an zweiter stelle
harald lesch mit einer doch sehr
deutlichen appell dass wir alle zusammen
mehr tun müssen wir sind gespannt was
die bundesregierung heute abend
beschließt ich mache noch mal ein
kommentar von ihnen die schreibt einfach
mal mehr urlaub in seinem heimatland
deutschland verbringen und auch sonst
versuchen nach regieren zu leben das
kommt ihm entgegen was sie gerade gesagt
haben dann kann jeder zumindest etwas
tun aber ich glaube das ganz große rad
müssen wir alle gemeinsam drehen
vielen dank so ist es für ihre zeit
heute abend und ich hoffe sie können
sich jetzt da drin im klima zählt noch
aufwärmen im klima pavillon bei uns ihr
seht ist es extrem muckelig warm ich
habe schon noch t shirt an
das ist heute nicht das freut mich sehr
dass ist bei euch möglich war alles gute
und dran bleiben dran war weiter weiter
weiter weiter weiter alles andere ist
bringt nichts ich danke ihnen herr lesch
für unser gespräch und bis bald
vielen dank für die kommentare und für
die vielen fragen ich hoffe wir konnten
einiges klären und den nächsten live
stream gibt es dann nächsten dienstag
wieder um 20 30 im internetkanal eures
vertrauens ich hoffe ihr seid dabei bis
dahin sage ich macht gut und tschüss
und wenn er mehr zum thema wissen wollt
hier oben haben wir über das feindbild
suv gesprochen oder hier gibt es den
live stream mit scientist future über
klimaschutz und natürlich bitte nicht
vergessen unseren neuen kanals
abonnieren vielen dank